alessio fi galli e nel professor of
mathematics a ttg zurich
prof
consists of file
ipes possible way of transport investors
from one placed on other this problem
comes from economics but it and south
web many applications mathematics in
particular one next application
exposed by all the shape crystals  change
under beac sono vestire of horses the
basic e via is that you can't take the
deal ceppo va crystal the one that le
sei e quel shaun spread it but when you
don't take two account
a shape the crystal were perhaps
you will be thing e new canta you try to
transport del finismo al particles that
are compose hingis crystals from the be
all and configuration tool del real
configuration and by understanding audis
particles moon
io cana jolie understand a lot about the
shape of  christmas in the follows i open
iustis prinzi very stable brusciano
klaus de besi principle disk there is a
certain cloud look in top time and
anne  hurd the next instant of time
particles smog and smoke and extend
fine particles heawood again uk and
kyle field rissa optimal transport
behind it and by using his i guess
that the get is born for i could models
there is no real universal
ehi tu audio approach  problem every
problem is it son specifics nate proprio
income son geometri for instance bathroom
states de jeu wrist bubbles jumper
geometrica intuition because you can see
the geometrical object uk andro pictures
l6 by just a look in around you doing
esperimenti vendetta lo trovi di also
be true  path to fall of the same thing i
spit probst comes from physics deal
physics intuition that will tell you what
went through this means ed alza moment
to start gliussi mathematics using
analysis means that you really al to
work with formulas and that moment i
tasks framework  you just have you and
your piece of death and your imagination
to try to make a geometriche intuition
assisi intuition apr into th  e formulas
so being able to bru bru formulas that
the passion year studying crudi model
of the phenomenon of molto d'escrime and he
is really santi which is difficult e
splaine but is beautiful is like art and
recreational